foreign
[Music]
this is the moment baby the drag queens
are coming
you would think we were like Jurassic
Park you know where the glass the water
just start shaking that's our heels
coming
I love it that's the preview of season
three of HBO Max show we're here
starring RuPaul's race Alum Eureka
O'Hara
she's joining us in studio to say she's
here at the Garden yeah the lounge and
bar just announced their winter event
lineup but first Eureka we want to know
more about the HBO Max show the new
season coming up well we're here season
three it just premiered last Friday so
our second episode is tomorrow night so
make sure y'all check it out on HBO Max
um it is available 10 p.m Eastern Time 7
PM Pacific
um it's an HBO original actually so it
airs on HBO but also it is available to
stream at the same time but what's going
on though what's happening you know I I
don't as you all know I hope at least
you've seen in the news and some of the
issues that we've had with lgbtq
politics this year
um we've also had a tragedy happen
recently in Colorado Springs you know
our show goes into small towns and we
put highlighted spotlights on small town
living
um queer injustices as we Spotlight Ally
stories things like that what we do is
we bring a community involvement
together in that town by inviting them
to a one-time drag show where we put
free Protege so each of us have a drag
child that we put in Drag and we put on
a show that represents what story
they're telling
them this brings healing yeah
yeah and it's almost like that
therapeutic performance aspect too and
how much therapy performing and finding
that confidence with yourself it can
help so much absolutely but speaking of
fun we're here there are watch parties
at the Garden so tell us all about that
too so the garden is being so gracious
it's the home bar that I'm kind of
taking over in my own way
um I just moved here two months ago I
have a spot in L.A still but okay I
wanted like a home space and you know
I'm gonna be honest houses are a little
cheaper here than L.A okay so uh we're
here is going to be doing or excuse me
the garden we're doing we're here
viewing shows every Friday night at 9 00
PM I'm where I host and like I saw my
friend's house from time to time if I'm
at drag race live because I'm also doing
drag race live for December at the
Flamingo girl you know once they get me
in a city honey they're like where can
we pull you what direction can we take
you
every month you have these Eureka Castle
parties right you tell us about those so
I came up with the idea for Eureka's
Castle play on words from a childhood TV
show that I loved but also you know I've
competed for Rupaul's Drag Race several
times and not won the crown made it to
the top honey but didn't win the crown
so Mama decided to build a castle with
the stones they threw at her okay so uh
Eureka's Castle is just very much a
place where everyone's invited to feel
like royalty you know and and that's
what we've spread is positivity and love
through having diverse entertainment
um uplifting conversation but also just
having fun and making fun of each other
and life and just celebrating uh for the
whole night and we really try to cater
especially to the local queer Community
here too as well as bring in tourists
but I think we wanted to create more of
a home space too where locals can feel
safe and feel like they have a community
spot to come to and have a safe space
absolutely now the garden and you know
there's a whole lineup of things
happening for the winter season can you
talk about that now so the garden has
you know they have brunches on Saturdays
and Sundays which are you know a cast of
incredible entertainers there are
several RuPaul's Drag Race girls that
work those shows as well they also have
a shade Thursday which is tonight with
Reese's Sexton as their host uh my good
sister Patrona Evans is in town
um she is a Powerhouse black Trans woman
Entertainer who you all do not want to
miss but yeah they have these weekly
shows every week the brunches which are
really incredible and then of course
Friday and Saturday night shows and
events and then obviously Eureka's
Castle the last Saturday of every month
so don't miss it I don't want to go to
Eureka's Castle yes we need to what's
going down why how about the bouncy
house Archway made for the interviews so
it's like Eureka's Castle bouncy house I
love it it's so cute congratulations on
all your success and everything you got
going on thank you yeah you do have a
lot on yourself it's a lot going on like
this dress
you can see here Eureka perform this
Sunday at the garden's bottomless brunch
just visit the gardenlasvegas.com for
your ticket yeah all right